[Applauso]
il primo rob down nel 2020 è stato
fantastico non sono andato a scuola mi
svegliavo facevo le video lezioni a
letto
finite le elezioni accendevo netflix e
mi guardavo le serie preferita ci avevo
già visto ovviamente 10 15 volte
verso le 3 si verso di te è cominciato a
sentire fame così con arrivo in cucina
apriva un frigorifero e mi facevo un
buonissimo panino accompagnato della
coca cola ha la felicità una bella
storia anche se non è in realtà che è
andata così perlomeno per me
buongiorno a tutti io sono mattia
fiorino e ho 17 anni sono un ragazzo
fortunato in salute amato con amici
relazioni passioni eppure ci siamo posti
tutti molte domande questo periodo
quelli che mi sono posto io più di
frequente sono perché sono più le volte
in cui mi sento triste rispetto a quello
in cui mi sento felice perché sono più
le volte in cui penso al futuro
ripenso al passato e in questo ping pong
di passato futuro mi sfugge il presente
perché non ringrazia la vita di tutto
ciò perché nonostante io sia consapevole
di questa mia fortuna non riesco a jury
sniffano in fondo
torniamo knock down siamo stati mesi
chiusi in casa all'inizio eravamo tutti
felici
ah che bello un po di vacanze tanto
torneremo tanto torneremo torneremo
giusto
e stato più di un anno con ulteriori
aperture e chiusure e la scuola le
relazioni tutto hanno cominciato a
mancarci abbiamo cominciato ad
apprezzare pure i professori per farvi
capire ci mancava la nostra quotidianità
anche il suono della sveglia alle sei
del mattino il peso dello zaino e spalla
questo perché nel momento in cui
perdiamo una cosa
impariamo ad apprezzarla cogliendone il
vero valore
allora rivedi la bellezza
dell'incontrarsi nel cortile
prima di entrare a scuola la gioia del
suono della campanella che annuncia
l'inizio dell'intervallo le risate nei
corridoi la complicità dei compagni ha
anche il sapore del caffè alla
macchinetta quale alle lezione da
imparare apprezzare ciò che abbiamo
prima di perderlo perché attendere di
perdere le cose che abbiamo prima di
goderne
credo che in fondo questa sia la
felicità la consapevolezza
se cercate su internet
la definizione di gratitudine troverete
sentimento di affettuosa riconoscenza
per un beneficio i benefici a volte sono
vestiti lotte sfide sofferenze dentro il
dolore si è nascosta la nostra crescita
la nostra forza l'infinita meraviglia di
cui è fatta la nostra vita
provate a leggere un libro o a vedere un
film dove tutto vada bene dove non ci
sia un malvagio una lotta o un
antagonista che tra i mille peripezie al
personaggio principale
se non ci fossero gli antagonisti vi
annoiereste dopo le prime due scene chi
sarebbe cappuccetto rosso senza il lupo
una povera svampita che raccoglie i
fiorellini
e invece peter pan chi sarebbe senza
capitan uncino e sui pirati
attenzione non voglio dire che il dolore
dobbiamo andarci a cercare ma forse
accoglierlo accettarlo affrontarlo e
sentirlo come un'opportunità per
trasformarlo in beneficio
adesso voglio fare un gioco con voi
quanti di voi hanno ringraziato almeno
una volta la vita perché il giorno in
cui doveva essere interrogati
la prof.sa non era venuta a scuola
però voglio che avete le mani quindi per
cortesia su un po di coraggio alzate le
mani grazie grazie
perfetto non siate timidi tanto non vi
vedono perfetto bravi
quanti di voi hanno ringraziato almeno
una volta la vita perché non vi siete
fatti beccare dai vostri genitori mentre
gli nascondeva te qualcosa soltanto non
ci sono telecamere che vi riprendono
quindi ok bene perfetto
adesso quanti di voi hanno ringraziato
almeno una volta la vita per essere
risvegliati grande andresti
ultima giura quanti di voi hanno
ringraziato almeno una volta la vita per
non essere oggi in ospedale intubati la
pandemia ci ha tolto tanto ma ci ha
permesso di riflettere su molte cose a
cui non davamo conto prima abbiamo
imparato a leggere i sorrisi oltre gli
sguardi a sentire gli abbracci oltre la
pelle ho capito che anche se il mio
spazio calpestabile e ha ridotto a una
stanza il mio spazio interno fatto di
musica parole immagini e immenso dentro
di me ha ospitato la crescita
il suo nome è arte grazie
[Applauso]